foreign
throwing a ball up into the air the
harder you throw it the faster it
travels and the higher it goes before
falling back down if you threw it hard
enough it would actually fly away from
the earth like a rocket but what if the
Earth was condensed to the volume of a
marble no matter how hard you threw your
ball it would always fall back down to
you it could never escape this
marble-sized Earth has essentially
become a black hole a region of space
with a gravitational field so strong
that nothing not even light can escape
let's go back to when the Earth was at
its normal volume the speed that an
object must be traveling at when it
leaves the surface of the Earth is
called the Earth's escape velocity the
escape velocity of the Earth depends on
the gravitational pull that the Earth
exerts on the object that's trying to
escape gravity is an attractive force
between objects with mass the
gravitational force between two objects
depends on their mass and the distance
between their centers the greater their
masses and the shorter the distance
between each object the greater
gravitational pull one exerts on the
other and therefore the higher the
escape Velocity must be since the mass
of the earth is many times larger than
the objects we launch from it the mass
of the object is considered
insignificant and scientists only
consider the Earth's mass when
determining how fast an object like a
rocket where your ball has to go to
escape the Earth in such an estimation
the Earth's escape velocity is about 39
000 kilometers per hour roughly 50 times
faster than the average speed of an
airplane
now let's revisit our marble-sized Earth
in this scenario the Earth is smaller in
diameter but unchanged in Mass the
escape Velocity will be higher since an
object on the Earth's surface would be
much closer to its Center
if we were to continue squishing the
Earth the escape Velocity would approach
the speed of light nothing can move
faster than the speed of light so your
ball or any object for that matter could
never achieve a high enough velocity to
escape the compressed Earth this is how
the Earth would become a black hole
a hundred years ago the existence of
black holes was speculation scientists
had developed numerous theories that
used black holes as tools for
understanding the fundamental laws of
the universe like explaining the
beginning of time in this way scientists
had mathematical proof that black holes
must exist but little physical evidence
to support the theory after all how can
you see something from which no light
escapes
astrophysicists theorized that they
could Instead try to capture the
silhouette of a black hole
since black holes exert an extremely
strong gravitational pull any nearby
matter is rapidly drawn towards them
creating an accretion disk that spirals
inward the accretion disk exists just
outside of a black hole's Event Horizon
which can be thought of as the point of
no return anything that passes The Event
Horizon will be sucked in by the intense
gravity of the black hole due to
frictional heating the fast-moving
matter in the accretion disk glows
emitting light this light is bent by the
gravity of the black hole creating a
glowing ring that we can see in 2019
scientists did just that they observed a
ring of light emanating from an
accretion disk this visually confirmed
the existence of black holes for the
first time in history using an array of
eight ground-based telescopes across our
planet astrophysicists captured images
of a massive black hole at the center of
Messier 87 a Galaxy 55 million light
years from Earth this major breakthrough
served to support decades-old scientific
theories about black holes and even some
of the stories that science fiction
authors had written about them with
increasingly complex technology that
allows us to observe the depths of our
universe at higher resolution scientists
increase our understanding of cosmic
phenomena and find new questions to ask
ranging from the potential to harvest
energy from a black hole to discovering
plasma Jets streams of energy and hot
matter that spew from the center of
black holes with a gravitational force
so immense it's no wonder that
scientists can't escape the irresistible
Mysteries hidden deep within black holes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]